[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCOTT LEVINE: Univision
NOW is our direct consumer
subscription
offering, and the goal
was to give access to our
audience, wherever they are,
whenever they want.
When we really wanted
to innovative and push
the boundaries on our
subscription service,
we launched in-app
subscriptions for Google Play.
And we saw it pop immediately,
about three to four
times the conversion rate by
working with the Google team.
ELIE HABIB: When
we started Anghami,
we said we want to have a music
service which is convenient
and all the music available.
In the Middle East,
it was a region
which was totally forgotten.
There was no legal alternative.
So you have to pirate or pirate.
I mean, there was nothing else.
And if we actually
could succeed,
we'd be pirating the pirates.
For us, Google Play is the core.
We have over 81% of our
users today on Android.
Our growth strategy
goes around engaging
Android users to use the app
more so they can subscribe.
AHCENE AMROUZ: We think that
Google Play billing really
helped the increase of our
subscription conversion rates
on [? Le Matinal. ?]
And we think
that one of main explanations
is the better user experience.
Android has become
the main source
for downloads for
[? Le Matinal. ?] Also, we
see, on subscription conversion,
an increase of 6% on Android
compared to other platforms.
KONRADIN BREYER: Freeletics
was started with a vision
to make everyone the greatest
version of themselves.
And the way we do this is we're
trying to motivate and guide
them in a variety
of apps to reach
their physical and mental goals.
The reason why subscriptions
make a lot of sense for us
is not only from an
economic point of view,
but also because we want to
develop people in the long run.
We want to have a repeated
impact upon their life.
SCOTT LEVINE: Working
with Google Play
and figuring out how to launch
a successful subscription
product, it's been great.
And that kind of
partnership is really
what we saw that
led to the success.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TOM GRINSTED: Good
morning, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
So first off, well done for
making it in on Friday morning.
And from me and these
two, thank you very much.
Hello to everyone on
the livestream as well.
I want to dive straight into
it, and I want to dive straight
into it with all of you.
So can you all put
your hands up, please?
Every single one of you.
I'm going to shame
anyone who doesn't.
[LAUGHING]
Brilliant.
OK, if you're on the livestream,
could you put them up--
keep them up.
If you're on the
livestream, could you
put your hand up as
well, just so you
look really odd in your office?
OK, could you put
your hand down if you
don't want to make more money?
Actually, someone just put
their hand up in the front row.
That's amazing.
It's like, "No, me too.
OK, thanks very much.
You can put your hands down now.
OK, so the good news is, you're
all in the right session,
because this is all about making
more money with subscriptions
and with Google Play.
Now, why subscriptions?
Well, basically,
subscriptions are,
we think, the best way
to make more revenue
more regularly and more
reliably on Google Play.
And who doesn't want
to make more cash more
reliably and more regularly?
But all of you guys
are going to be
at different parts of your
subscription life cycle.
All of you are going to
be at different points
in integrating with us.
Now, the three of us are really
excited about subscriptions,
but we'd also like to know a
bit more about you as well.
So I want you to get
your hands ready again.
Can you give a thought about
where you are in your app
development journey?
And if you've integrated
with Play Billing,
so you're running subscriptions
in your apps right now
and you're running a
successful business,
but you want to know how
to take that business
to the next level, can
you put your hands up?
So can you put your hands up
if you've integrated with us
but want to know how to
really drive success?
Great, thanks so much.
Put your hands down.
OK, so next, if you've just
started integrating with us,
maybe you're at the
beginning of your journey,
or you're considering
it, and you
want to know what tools
we have to help you build
your successful
subscriptions business,
can you put your
hands up, please?
OK, a few of you.
Thanks very much.
And lastly, if you've
not integrated with us,
if you're maybe considering
subscriptions or considering
using us, basically, if
you're here because you just
want to know what all the fuss
is about with subscriptions,
can you put your hands up?
OK, a few of you.
Hello, and welcome.
So the good news
is that no matter
when you put your hands up or
if you're on the livestream,
if you thought, that sounds
like me, then Larry, George,
and I have things
to share with you.
So today, we're
going to be talking
to every single one of
you in the room about how
Play can help you build
successful subscription
businesses.
Now, the three of us work
with teams across Google
to make that happen.
That means that we've been
thinking about subscriptions
a huge amount.
And when we do, we think
it starts with one thing.
It starts with an
awesome product.
And that's on you guys.
You guys make amazing apps
that bring Android to life.
So you've done that.
You've got a
brilliant app, and you
want to monetize it
with subscriptions.
What's the next thing you need?
Well, the next thing you
need is a brilliant market.
You need loads of
people who are really
interested in your product and
are willing to pay to use it.
But that's not all, either.
The next thing you need is a
best-in-class billing platform
that gives you guys the
tools and the flexibility
to be able to get
to that audience
and successfully monetize them.
Now, once you've
got those, there's
one more thing you need to
build a truly successful
subscriptions
business, and that's
best-in-class insights
and reporting.
Because the better the
insights you guys have,
the better decisions you make.
And when you make
great decisions,
you build great businesses.
So the good news is
that no matter where
you put your hands up,
we've got something for you.
If you're wondering what
all the fuss is about,
George is going to be
sharing information
about the amazing market you
find on Android and via Play.
If you put your hands
up because you're
really interested in our
tooling, current and new,
Larry's going to be showing
some really exciting information
about the new capabilities
of our billing platform.
And lastly, if you
put your hands up
because you want to take your
business to the next level,
you need the insights
to be able to do that,
and I'll be on at
the end to share
some really exciting
information about new insights
and reporting via
the Play console.
So let's get going.
I'd like to welcome George
up to tell us, really,
what all the fuss is about.
GEORGE AUDI: Thanks, Tom.
Hey, everyone.
I'm George, and I'm on the
Play Business Development team,
working with developers like
yourselves on your subscription
business.
I am very happy to
be here, particularly
because subscriptions are
seeing a phenomenal growth
on Androids.
Just in the past two years,
we have doubled the number
of active subscribers on Play.
So between 2016 and 2017,
we have twice the number
of people subscribing
to your services,
and this proves that there
is an audience of users
that is really interested in
engaging with your products.
But that's not all.
That's actually only
the latest in a series
of positive momentum
we've been seeing.
Subscriptions have been the
fastest growing business
model on Google Play today.
We've seen a 10 times growth
in the past three years
in consumer spend.
So not only are people
using your services,
they are also spending on them.
Now, to validate this,
we actually really
talked with users
and developers,
and we know that this
phenomenal growth would not
happen if users don't
love subscriptions.
Fortunately, they do.
Personally, I love being able
to binge-watch the latest
season of "Sense8" on
Netflix, or track my workouts
on Freeletics, or even
swipe as much as I want
on Tinder without having
to worry about consumption
charges and extra fees.
And that's why users
love subscriptions.
They know that they can
engage in your product
as much as they want
and know that they
will be charged that $5, $10,
$15 at the end of the month.
So I mentioned the
consumer research study
that we did recently
to better understand
subscribers on Androids.
And the study really validated
this trend, and this growth,
and this excitement
about subscriptions
that we're seeing.
We realize that the
audience for subscriptions
is out there and very engaged.
62% of subscribers on Androids
use their subscription service
at least once a day.
Now, this engagement
translates into money.
We found that there
is a compelling market
for subscriptions coming
out of these engaged users.
There is a willingness to pay
that ranges anywhere between $5
and $20 for subscriptions,
and that really varies based
on the category of the app.
We will be making the results of
this consumers research survey
available to you
today in a blog post,
so make sure to check
it out so you can better
understand subscription
trends on Androids.
Now, let's switch sides
to you guys in the room.
We know that developers
also love subscriptions.
Otherwise, you wouldn't be
here at 10:00 AM on a Friday.
Developers love subscriptions,
because you can generate
recurrent revenue from
happy and engaged buyers,
and who doesn't want that?
Who doesn't want
the peace of mind
that your users are
paying you every month?
It's expected, it's
recurrent, and it's very easy
to model out.
Thousands of developers
use Google Play billing
for their subscriptions today.
Some of them are
here on the screen.
And some of them have
actually shared with us
a bunch of their case
studies and stories
about the success that
they're seeing on Androids.
So throughout this
session, you will
hear from Tinder, Netflix,
Coffee Meets Bagel, HBO,
and many others.
So there are loads of great
reasons to choose subscriptions
and to choose Play
billing for subscriptions.
The first of these is how huge
and addressable the market
for subscription on
Android is, but also
how easy it is to
integrate with us.
And Larry will touch a
bit more on this later
throughout this talk.
But let me tell you
about the market.
You may have heard
this incredible stat
from the keynote
a few days ago--
2 billion monthly active
devices on Android today.
That's pretty good, right?
These are billions
of users that you
can reach through
Google Play billing
with a simple integration.
We enable you to sell your
subscriptions to billions
of users across the world.
Now, this is pretty cool,
but it's also somewhat scary.
It's pretty complex
to put together
a subscription business.
Think of it-- you have to
worry about local market
understanding,
regulations, taxes.
I mean, who doesn't love
to think about taxes
across the world, right?
Refunds, order
management-- so many things
have to come together to create
a compelling subscription
product.
Luckily, we take all
of that away from you.
We do a huge amount of that for
you so that all you have to do
is plug and play,
no pun intended.
So Coffee Meets
Bagel, for example,
is a case study of an app in
the dating space who typically
had been using in-app
purchases, but wanted
to get in on the all the
frenzy around subscriptions
and wanted to introduce
a subscription
SKU in their product.
By partnering with
Google Play, they
were able to do so very quickly,
and within a few months,
they were offering a
subscription SKU globally
without having to worry about
local payment integrations,
various regulations, et cetera.
All they did is create
a subscription SKU,
integrate with Play Billing,
and now subscriptions generate
40% of the revenue for
Coffee Meets Bagel.
All right, so we've
established that the audience
for subscription
services is out there,
engaged, and willing to pay.
The Android market is
huge, with billions
of users that you can
reach, and that it's
very easy to integrate
with Google Play Billing.
So now, Larry will tell us
about the billing platform
and how the global reach and
innovative features of Play
Billing can really help you
propel your subscription
business to success.
Larry?
LARRY YANG: Thanks, George.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Larry Yang.
I'm the product manager for the
Google Play billing platform.
When I think about
subscription success,
I think it really just comes
down to two key factors--
acquisition and retention.
Let me walk you through
some of the key features
that the Play Billing
platform provides
to help you in these two areas.
First, let's talk
about acquisition.
Play Billing offers
three important tools
to help you acquire new users.
We bring you our
extensive payment reach,
we have amazing
introductory features,
and last, but probably
most important,
we have an amazingly simple
user payment experience.
Let's talk about our
payment reach first.
Google Play Billing is available
in over 130 countries today.
But it's not enough just to
offer any old form of payment.
You need to offer the
preferred form of payment.
And it turns out,
payment preferation
is more a function
of culture than it
is socioeconomic status.
For example, in North
America, of course,
credit cards are very popular.
But it turns out Paypal is
super important in Germany
and other European countries.
In regions where
cash is still king,
our Play credit and gift
cards have been a big hit.
And in the Asia Pacific region
and throughout the Middle East,
carrier billing is a must-have.
Let me talk a little bit more
about these last two-- gift
cards and carrier billing.
We've offered our gift
cards for a while now
to allow users to
purchase Play content,
and earlier this year,
we extended that ability
to subscriptions.
In areas where cash
is still very popular,
we've seen a tremendous
increase in subscriptions spent,
in some areas, as high as 15%.
So we're super excited to
bring this new form of payment
to your subscriptions business.
Now, let's talk a bit
about carrier billing.
Earlier this week,
you might have
heard us announce that we
now have billing partnerships
with over 140 mobile carriers.
And across all
those partnerships,
we now reach 900
million active devices.
That's 900 million
devices whose users
can now pay for your content
directly from their phone.
They don't need a credit card.
They don't need a bank account.
They just need their phone.
So those are a few examples
of our payment reach
and how that helps you
grow your business.
Now, let's talk about some
of our flexible introductory
capabilities.
We've had free trial
support for a while now.
It's a great way for you
to introduce your content
to prospective subscribers
without them having
to make a long-term commitment.
It turns out, when we talk
to users, over 3/4 of them
started a subscription
offering with some sort
of free experience.
So it's no wonder that almost
all of our top subscription
apps and partners all offer
some sort of free experience.
Now, in addition to free
trials, last year, we
offered introductory pricing.
This gives you the ability
to offer a limited time
discount for your service.
When we talked to
users, we learned
that getting some
sort of a discount
was the number two
driver for conversion,
and that was second only
to the desire of wanting
to get continued and
additional content.
And that makes sense.
After all, who doesn't
love a great deal?
GEORGE AUDI: Larry,
actually, a great example
of a developer who ran
an introductory pricing
campaign is Anghami.
Anghami is the leading music
streaming service in the Middle
East, and they have a
premium access which allows
you to get unlimited music.
Now, Anghami is usually
priced at $5 a month,
but they did a weekend promotion
where they offered the service
for $3 for three months.
So that's about 80% in savings.
The results were impressive.
They saw a 400% increase
in daily average orders
during that weekend compared to
their average daily sign-ups.
That's five times the number of
buyers going in and signing up
to the service.
And interestingly,
after three months,
after the promotion was over,
the majority of these users
actually ended up staying
on the service and recurring
at full price.
LARRY YANG: Thanks, George.
That's a great example of
how one of our developers
is seeing subscription
success with our platform.
So now, let me talk
about our third tool that
helps you acquire new users--
our seamless user
payment experience.
Imagine a free-for-all
world where
users have to read multiple
different terms of services.
They have to enter their
sensitive information
multiple times--
sometimes their address,
sometimes their zip code,
sometimes other
information-- and they
have to do that over,
and over, and over again.
Well, that nightmare is over.
Play Billing makes it simple.
The user enters their
payment information
once and never again.
And it turns out that the
majority of our purchases
finish without the user
having to enter their payment
information.
And besides, as a
developer, do you really
want to be maintaining
and managing all
of that sensitive information?
Of course not.
So instead of entering
their information
with multiple companies, they
just do it once with Google.
And when we asked
users how felt,
they told us it just feels safe.
And why does safety
and trust matter?
It turns out the
more users trust
the company they work
with, the more likely
they're going to spend money.
68% of users associate trust
with making a purchase.
That was the number
one correlated factor
in this survey.
GEORGE AUDI: Larry,
I'm standing here
because I have a feeling I'm
going to keep interrupting you
throughout.
Actually, I just want to add
that this seamless experience,
and this trust that developers
put into Google Play,
and the ease of the
flow delivers results.
We've seen that at the
moment of purchase,
you really want to
capture this intent
with as minimal
friction as possible,
as few steps as possible.
With Google Play Billing, you
can do it with only two steps,
and this is translating into
positive conversion results
for some of our partners.
For example, the
"New York Times,"
when they introduce
Google Play Billing,
they saw a 125%
increase in conversions
just one month after doing so.
Univision NOW, when they
launched their subscription
service and moved it from
a web-based payment flow
to Google Play Billing, they
saw a spike of three to four
times conversion lift.
And you saw on the video
about [? Le Matinal, ?]
which sees 6% better
conversions on Androids
than on non-Android platforms.
So if you look at
this all together,
this means that we take the
effort out of implementation,
but we also deliver results.
And this is why HBO
decided to use and rely
on Google Play Billing for their
subscription service HBO Now,
because we allow an end-to-end
experience to users where they
don't have to remove their
credit card from their wallet,
but we also allow an
end-to-end payment platform
for HBO, which enables
them to, again,
just plug and play and
get going immediately.
LARRY YANG: Thanks, George.
So those are some
examples of how
our payment reach, our
introductory features,
and our payment experience
help you acquire new users.
So now that you have all
these great, happy, new users,
let me talk about
a couple things
we do to help you keep
them, help you retain them.
So last year, we
launched a feature--
Grace Period.
Grace Period is a way for you to
give your users three or seven
extra days to correct any
sort of payment issues
that might have happened
when they were renewing
their subscription.
Well, it turns
out the developers
who are using Grace
Period are seeing
over a 50% improvement
in recovery
from those sorts of
involuntary cancellations.
So if you're a developer
with subscriptions,
and you're not already
using Grace Period,
you really should just get
on the Play console right
now and turn on that feature.
It's literally just
flipping a switch.
But there's still a
problem with Grace Period.
Users are lazy.
It's just too easy for them
to dismiss a notification
or ignore an email and
keep consuming your content
without having to pay for it.
So today, I'm pleased
to announce we're
rolling out a new feature--
Account Hold.
With Account Hold, we work
with you to block access
to your precious content.
So now we've increased
the level of pain
just enough for the user.
Now they need to
actually go and fix
that form of payment in order to
restore access to your content.
We have over a dozen developers
in Early Access right now using
Account Hold, and we
plan on bringing that
out a little later next month.
GEORGE AUDI: So we
piloted this feature
with KeepSafe, which is one
of those developers who were
in the Early Access program.
KeepSafe is an app which
allows you to store your photos
and videos and protect
them so you can have PIN
protection around your videos.
They're very popular on Android,
and they have a subscription
business which allows
you, as a premium user,
to access your
photos in the Cloud
and various other
exciting features.
Now, because their
subscription service
is really important
for them, they
integrated with Account Hold,
and they saw this 25% increase
in renewal rates on Androids.
And this is because,
to Larry's point, when
users get this notification that
their account will be suspended
unless they change
their form of payment,
they are much more likely
to go and act on it.
So these are a few examples
of how the Google Play Billing
platform helps you build
a successful subscription
business.
And speaking of success,
one of the partners
that we have worked
with very closely
is Netflix, which is
the leading subscription
service in the world.
We've partnered very
closely with them
to enable them to scale
their app globally,
but also to make payment
effortless through Google
Play Billing for Netflix
subscribers around the world.
The figures and the acquisition
and the retention numbers
that Netflix is seeing
through Google Play Billing
are very promising and are
delivering subscription success
in over 100 countries.
LARRY YANG: But that's not all.
Our team's been
listening to you,
and they're hard at work on
a number of new capabilities
that we'll be rolling out soon.
We're going to give you more
flexibility in how you set up
and offer your SKUs.
We're going to make it easier
for you to change prices
on your existing subscriptions.
We're going to give you more
up-to-date information when
a subscription status changes,
say, when a user cancels
or they go on hold.
And we're going
to make it easier
for you to integrate and
test with Play Billing.
So stay tuned over
the next few months.
So now that you have all
these amazing new tools
at your fingertips, how do
you know which ones to try?
How do you know what's working?
How do you know which
ones aren't working?
Well, in order to
answer those questions,
you need fantastic
insights and reporting.
Tom, why don't you
share some of the stuff
that your team is
working on in this area?
TOM GRINSTED: Cool.
Thanks, Larry.
Hello again, everybody.
So I work with teams in
Google Play, some of whom
are actually in the audience.
Hello, everyone.
Now, the huge advantage
of Google Play
is that we are, for all
intents and purposes,
the single point of truth
for a number of key events
in your life cycle.
These are events like people
looking at your Play Store
listing, installing your app,
taking out your free trial,
or every single recurrent
payment for a subscriber.
Now, it's that team's job
to get that information out
to you guys in a way which
is actionable and insightful.
Basically, we're dedicated in
getting subscription metrics
out to all developers who
are running subscriptions
businesses.
If I'm honest, the Play
console hasn't been fantastic
at that in the past.
But we know that you need
that information to run
your businesses
and make decisions,
which is why I'm really happy
to say that earlier this week,
we launched a brand-new
part of the Play console--
the Subscriptions dashboard.
The Subscriptions
dashboard is easily
found in the Revenue
section on the Play menu,
and it pulls together key
overarching information
about your subs.
So, for instance, it easily
plots total subscriptions
and new activations and
cancellations all in one place.
It also pulls together
your bottom line,
so it shows you your daily
and 30-day rolling revenue.
And lastly, it even
easily displays your top
performing products.
Taken together, this
dashboard is a brilliant place
to gain insights, to
look at your trends,
and to spot anomalies.
But when you do
that, you're even
going to want to
know more, right?
You're going to see
something, and you're
going to want to dive into
it and really understand
what's going on.
Now, when you do
want to know more,
we have the bottom
half of the dashboard.
This is a super
powerful cohortized view
of new subscribers, And
it looks at the three
key parts of your
subscription life cycle--
acquisition, retention,
and cancellation.
So let's take a look at each
one of those nice and quickly.
Now, to start off with,
we've got acquisition--
how you acquire new subscribers,
where they came from,
and also, which
acquisition channels they
were coming in from as well.
Now, this card is
lovely, but it's not
the only information we have.
So the Acquisition Report,
like the other two,
has a really powerful
click-through report as well.
So this gives you
much more information
about your subscriptions
acquisition.
It's built on the really
successful acquisition
reports you can already
find in the Play console,
but it's tailored specifically
to your subscriptions business.
So you can see not only which
of your acquisition channels
drove the highest number of
free trialists or installs,
but also which drove
the largest number
of long-term, recurrent,
high-value subscribers.
Like the current acquisition
channels, we have breakdowns.
So you can see it
if you're using
UTM tagging against every
single one of your campaigns.
You can link to
AdWords to see it
against your paid-for
campaigns with Google.
Or you can even look at which
Google Search traffic drives
the highest number of
long-term subscribers.
It's a super
powerful way for you
to gain insights so you
can decide where you're
going to focus your
acquisition effort
and your acquisition
budget to get
you the highest number
of high-value recurrent
subscribers.
So what do you do next?
What do you do when you've
got these subscribers?
Well, you want to
know what happens
to them with your subscription.
And for that, we've got the
Subscriptions Retention Report.
This is brand-new,
and personally, I
think it's my favorite report.
It gives you a
cohort of subscribers
from different subscriptions
so you can plot different subs
against each other.
It allows you to see key parts
of your subscription life
cycles.
So in this case, this
developer can easily
see that just after
their free trial,
they see a large
drop-off in subscribers.
This enables you to make really
impactful product decisions.
In this case, the
developer might
choose to remind
their subscribers just
before their free trial ends of
what an amazing offer they have
or how fantastic
all the content is.
But that's not the
only thing this does.
This report also allows you
to easily select subscriptions
to compare to each other.
So if you've got a
brand-new subscription--
maybe it's a test one;
it's an experiment--
and you want to see
if it's performing
better or worse than your legacy
subs, you can easily see it.
And this enables you to make
really cool decisions, right?
In this case, the developer
might say, hey, look,
my subscription that's
represented by the red line,
clearly outperforming
the other ones,
this is the one I'm going to
put front and center in my app.
This is the one I'm going
to push to my users.
The Retention Report
enables you to make
the decisions that lead to
higher-value, longer-term
retained subscribers.
GEORGE AUDI: We actually
showed some of these mocks
to some developers
and workshops,
and the feedback has
been very positive.
So we're really excited for
all of you guys to try it out.
Glu is a developer of
subscription games,
and they were very excited
about this feature, the SKU
comparison one.
TOM GRINSTED: Yeah,
they loved it.
It was great to see as well.
Thank you.
So lastly, we've got
this sad report, right?
We've got the
Cancellation Report.
Nobody likes people
canceling your subscriptions,
but it does happen.
And the first step in
making it happen less
is to accept that it
happens and to find out why.
And for that, we've got
the Cancellation Report.
Now, for the first time,
the Cancellation Report
in the Play console allows
you to see the exact day
that subscribers
choose to cancel.
And to make it
really useful for you
guys to be able to work out
why, we helpfully categorize
these cancellations as well.
So let's take a look
at those categories.
To start off, we've got
voluntary cancellations.
Voluntary
cancellations are where
a user goes into the Play
app, finds your subscription,
and just taps "Cancel."
If you've got high
voluntary cancellations,
you can start doing
things like price testing.
Or maybe you want to
look at what value
you're offering
as part your sub,
or simply reminding users about
what a great value subscription
you really have.
Next, we've got Voluntary
Cancellation and Uninstall.
This is where someone not
only cancels your sub,
but after 30 days, they've
uninstalled your app
from every single
one of your devices.
GEORGE AUDI: That's painful.
TOM GRINSTED: Yeah, painful.
This is not a good cancellation.
If you've got high voluntary
and uninstall cancellations
this is the kind
of plan where you
want to start looking at
the new Android Vitals
section on the Play console to
take a look at whether you've
got high crashes, high
NRs, or a janky app.
Or maybe you want to take a
look at our new Advanced Reviews
Analysis to see what users
are telling you about your app
and where you can improve it.
And lastly, we've got
involuntary cancellations.
These are classically associated
with payment failures.
If you've got high
involuntary cancellations,
then the kind of
features that Larry
spoke about earlier like
Grace Periods and Account Hold
are exactly what you
should be looking at.
And the Cancellation
Report, especially when
it comes to Account
Hold, enables
you to build the
business model to be
able to put your Android
devs onto Account Hold
to build that feature out.
Taken together, this
gives you a view
into cancellations, which you've
never been able to have before.
But sometimes it's hard
to tell what to do,
so having that insight
is only the first step.
So launching with the
Cancellation Report,
then we're also starting to add
more and more active guidance.
This is where our teams
are saying to you, hey,
we've noticed this anomally.
You might want to try this tool.
It will help your
business get better.
So that is the dashboard,
a brand-new way
to look at all of your
subscriptions data on the Play
console, all in one place.
I'm really happy to say
that all of the time series
trends that you can
see up on the screens
now are available today
in the Play console.
And the second half,
those cohortized views
and click-throughs, will be
launched in the coming weeks.
I'd like to take just a second
to say why I and the teams
here really care about this.
We really, really care
about getting all of you
better subscriptions reporting.
And that's because we know that
better reporting allows all
of you to have better insights.
And the better your
subscriptions insights are,
the better the decisions
you make around them.
And the better decisions
you make around them,
the better businesses you
build, and the more successful
apps you run on Android.
GEORGE AUDI: Do you know who
really cares about this too,
Tom?
TOM GRINSTED: Who?
GEORGE AUDI: Tinder.
They said they will swipe
right to your new subscription
dashboard, so that's a match.
TOM GRINSTED: George,
all I've ever wanted
is someone to swipe right.
And I will take
on the dashboard.
LARRY YANG: All
right, so to wrap up,
what's all the fuss about?
Well, George told
you earlier about
how subscriptions is one of
the fastest growing businesses
and how a lot of developers
are already today taking
advantage of Android and Play
to grow their subscriptions
business.
TOM GRINSTED: And
if, at the beginning,
you really wanted to
know about the tools
that we have to
help you succeed,
Larry shared both existing
and brand-new tools
to help you really drive our
acquisition and your retention.
GEORGE AUDI: And across
it all, if you're
looking to improve
your subscription
business through
insights and reporting,
which can power your
decision-making,
Tom shared the latest in our
powerful new subscriptions
reporting tools.
So taken together,
all of this means
that Android is a great platform
to reach users, convert them,
generate more
revenue out of them,
and do so more regularly and
more reliably than ever before.
So thank you so
much for attending.
We will be here to take any
questions you might have.
So there are microphones
on each side of the room.
But before we do so, we
want to thank you again
for being here on behalf
of all three of us,
and we hope that you found
this session helpful.
[MUSIC PLAYING]